I like to be around people at work I
like to do things I've been working on
this thing that uh has been really fun
actually really kind of exciting also
because it's my own thing
um which has been kind of great you want
to elaborate on that well I wrote uh
I've writt I wrote with a friend of mine
named Dan Etheridge he and I have been
working on this like a series of it's
It's a small it's like four episodes but
it's
um like a narrative like an odd like for
audible you know like a series uh that's
been really kind of great because I
don't normally get the opportunity to
work on my own things like that is I'm
usually a Hired Gun so right right
um but it's been fun and I've been
working on it and recording it with my
friends which has been great Adam Scott
is in it oh great and uh Ken Marino who
I think you know and uh Celia Weston who
I actually did a play with many years
ago Ken Marino of uh the other two
obviously he is plays the manager he is
so goddamn funny oh he's hilarious I
mean that's a that's a fantastic show I
love that show but he is always makes me
laugh oh he's great part of that kind of
that state Collective we've worked
together a bunch and um but it's been
it's been cool there it's it's about
this guy named Ken Croft who has uh this
has hung his own shingle as being kind
of a publicist
um that a low rent publicist and he uh
it's kind of really at the end of his
rope things have just not gone well in
his life and he stumbles into this craft
store this sounds strange but uh this
there's a woman that's working there
from New Orleans who's been displaced uh
has ever since you know Katrina which is
years and years and years still but
she's still she's she's through and
through New Orleans and a very positive
person and he's smitten with her
immediately because she's wearing a
sweatshirt that just says uh beignet
done that
and uh and that would get me yeah and so
it's you kind of you see this it's very
sweet but funny in this kind of
relationship between these two people
and I actually brought we've recorded it
if you want to play a little bit of it
sure uh and it's with Celia Weston who's
playing we did a play years ago called
last night at Ballyhoo and I think and
this is where uh she is playing uh
Gladys who's the woman that's working in
the store I'm playing Ken uh even though
it's not Kim Reno who was in the show he
plays Carl but uh this is between Ken
Croft and Gladys and this is from our
podcast
oh for Christ's sake
why
why
you can't do this on a pot there he goes
wheelchair you can't do that on a
podcast that's why I didn't see it
coming right you can't do that on a
podcast yeah it's a visual joke I know I
swear to God how could I well that was
oh no it's never it's an audio medium I
know would it work that way I don't know
is there was there any truth to anything
you said in the setup no no Jesus none
of that was true the joke continues you
had me completely fooled honestly
because I didn't think it you can't do
that on a podcast yes you can no it
won't it such a waste I think all she
even says is Eric yeah yeah Eric yeah oh
trust me I know the clip pretty well
having watched it 160 000 times Well an
audience roared its approval and I grew
increasingly angry I thought it was
worth the attempt to just see how it
goes on it how is it you know what I
have to you know we're gonna find out
from the listeners please tell us uh you
just heard the Mac and Me clip totally
take me by surprise honestly I swear on
my life take me by surprise because I
did not think that could happen on a
podcast I don't think it can work on a
podcast but you have to tell me maybe it
does work Jesus I looked over I looked
at my producer Adam and he nodded like
no we have it and I thought well that's
weird they didn't tell me and and then I
see the beginning of the Mac and Me clip
I didn't even realize yeah there's a
computer there's a computer screen
played it yeah I didn't think they were
going to play it well how could it work
it off if I couldn't even see it oh I'd
hear Eric and I'd know and I know that
goddamn music and the sound of that the
sound of that wheelchair going over the
cliff
you're a terrible person it took me a
long time to realize
you really are